duck dynasty star Rebecca Lowe Robertson
and John Reeve Laughlin tie the knot
it's official the bride's father Willie
Robertson proudly walked his daughter
down the aisle at the intimate ceremony
surrounded by family and friends in
Mexico on Saturday the 28 year old
reality star dazzled in a gorgeous
Sherri Hill dress and cape with
intricate floral embroidery while there
pops donned a khaki suit and tie of
course in pure duck commander fashion he
accessorized his ensemble with a camo
print bandana and yeah I look so good on
you ahead of their vows Rebecca shared
this sweet photo with John at the
rehearsal dinner captioning it
surrounded by people we love tonight was
truly magical hashtag Laughlin wedded
wife the famous family also shared
adorable snaps of the couple's big day
to their social media accounts Rebecca's
sister and former Dancing with the Stars
contestant Sadie posted this beautiful
pic with her sister's writing in the
caption wow wow wow
what a wedding every single moment was
just absolutely priceless
I will cherish the memories forever I
love seeing my family grow
you